sie waren mal gesundheitsminister wenn
sie heute gesundheitsminister werden was
würden sie jetzt tun was raten sie
einsparen der schwer unter vorher steht
die entwicklung des impfstoffs ist eine
erfolgsgeschichte
noch nie gab es bei einer pandemie in so
kurzer zeit wirksame impfstoffe das darf
man nicht vergessen aber alles stehen
besser da usa israel in der
nachbarländer ist das zweite kapitel das
ist die verteilung des impfstoffes und
die quote der impfung und da ist es in
der tat verbesserung hätte man es besser
in deutschland machen sollen diese
entscheidung ein dass europäischen
richtig man hätte offensive und in
größerem umfang durchaus bestehen und
wer hat die fehler gemacht wir wollen
auch einen wir wollen auch wissen wer
den fehler gemacht hat
mit dem kenntnisstand von heute die
vergangenheit zu beurteilen da bin ich
immer sehr vorsichtig ich habe in der
tageszeitung der tagesspiegel die
berliner tageszeitung
ende juli gesagt wenn wir glück haben
haben wir ende des jahres einen
impfstoff diese meinung hat damals
niemand vertreten
ich bin belächelt worden ich bin
kritisiert worden
übrigens auch von bestimmten medien und
jetzt auch wirklich zu tun als mit dem
wissen von heute als hätte man das
wissen im juni auch schon aber jetzt
machen wir wieder versprechungen und
sagt wir haben bis dann und dann die
pflegeheime durchgehend wir haben bis
zum sommer angebot sollten die politiker
nicht so viele versprechungen machen die
sie dann am ende nicht halten können
dafür hier konkreten versprechungen sie
sich berufen ich sage nochmal wir tun
wir haben es mit einer außergewöhnlichen
situation zu tun die ist sehr ernst auch
das sehen nicht alle so
und wir haben es auch mit einer
situation wo wir alle immer wieder
stückchen dazulernen
bei der frage wie kann man diese riesige
herausforderung bewältigen dadurch
wirklich nichts zu kritisieren ich stehe
nicht in dem ruf dass ich mit kritik
zurückhalten wenn wenn es angemessen ist
aber ich habe jetzt nichts zu
kritisieren
wir müssen jeden tag dafür arbeiten dass
wird das ein oder andere noch abwehren
besser machen zum beispiel mit den 30
allerletzte frage was raten sie ansparen
als ehemalige gesundheitsminister was
sollte jetzt tun
ich habe ihn heute gesagt bleib auf
deinem weg
erkläre deine politik und behaltet
nerven
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren